rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message build trust with your customers
over to you Jack ma well we studied the
e-commerce nobody believed that China
would have incomes because people
believe on the one she face-to-face and
all kinds of networking traditional ways
there's no trusted system in China he
had to overcome centuries of tradition
by showing Chinese buyers and sellers
that they could trust
Alibaba with their money in this new
virtual world he did it by guaranteeing
the transactions and creating his own
payment system an escrow account where
Alibaba holds the buyers money until the
goods are delivered every day we finish
more than 13 minute rands actions and
that means that there you are buying
things from somebody you have never seen
you are giving products to the person
you have never met and there are some
guys you never know that he's going to
take your products to that place to that
person I want to tell the people that
trust is there because it's all about
it's all about the trust so I think it's
really important to understand what you
stand for as a human being and bring
that to your business when you can find
the one thing that makes you stand out
the one thing that you believe in then
it makes it so much easier for people to
talk about you for people to understand
what you do and for you to build a huge
empire that has a huge impact on the
world
so for jacket was trust everything is
about trust we need to build trust with
our customers Trust is super important
to him and so he ended up building a
leap a just the hang of this issue of
trust I am the guy that you trust
awesome if I look at TDS as an example
are the one word is family it's about
coming and being a part of a new family
when people sign up and take dance
classes they want to learn how to salsa
most people don't come trying to become
the best salsa dancer in the world and
to be honest if that's what you're
looking for
you shouldn't be taking a group class
anyway you'll learn faster working
one-on-one with an instructor instead of
being in a group class with everybody
our goal here is to have you have a
connection with people to have you have
a blast to have the class that you come
to be the highlight of your week that's
the bar that we set we're not as
concerned about teaching you the most
and making you the best dancer in the
world go take a day it's boot camp class
go take a private lesson with an
instructor who will beat you and make
you repeat it over and over and over and
over again we want you to have a blast
we want you to feel connected we want
you to be a part of the family that's
what we stand for that's why we
attracted people that we attract and
it's okay not to serve everybody not
everybody likes that people want to be a
salsa professional competition
choreographer
you can go here you can go over there a
group class ETDs it's not going to be
the best fit for you but if you want to
have fun you want to have the best time
of your life every week you want to look
forward to that Wednesday night class
ears this is the place to be and so it's
clear what we stand for it's clear what
Jack Ma stands for you need to be
equally as clear in your business what
are you staying for if people cannot
understand what's different about your
business what you stand for what your
one word is what you're all about
then you look like every other company
and it's hard to make a decision as to
why I should go with you versus somebody
else and I think in general
entrepreneurs tend to be a little too
corporate we look up to these big
corporations that we want to be like
them we want to look professional and
that's great you don't want to look
unprofessional but you're missing the
heart and soul the reason why people
work with entrepreneurs and small
businesses is the heart is your carrot
is your passion is what makes you
different and unique because if there's
nothing that's different or unique about
you then they're gonna just beat you
down on price and you never want to be
the low-cost provider so figure out what
your one hood is figure out what you
staying for match it to where that fits
in your market if Jack Ma is all about
trust here's how it applies to the
business that he's running he wants to
be the trusted person in this industry
that's how he's gonna win for people who
care about trust they're gonna go to him
for people who don't care about trust
people who just care about the lowest
price people who care about something
totally different they won't like Jack
Ma and that's okay because he doesn't
want to work with everybody he wants to
work with the people who are gonna be
ideal customers to him so figure out
what your one word is and how you can
apply it to your business so you can
start attracting ideal customers who
will love working with you who will buy
more from you who will spread the word
to their friends and so you can build
your empire to go have an amazing impact
on the world so the question today today
is I want to know what is the one thing
that you stay in for Jack mozz about
trust I'm going to believe GES is about
family what is it that you staying for
leave it down in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out now thank you
guys for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
once you develop a large customer base
and we reach about a hundred million
people everyone's of all our various
businesses our books our magazines or
television and once you develop that
kind of close rapport
they have already a feeling that I'm
providing them with things that you
don't want so it's very important to
engender trust with your customer if you
disappoint them I mean if you make
something that falls apart forget it you
don't get that customer back again and
all I want to do is grow my customer
base I want to be where that customer
needs and wants me with good stuff the
only thing you have is trust what is the
biggest most important thing a child
wants predictable environment from their
mother
that's called trust what's the only
thing you off with a teenager trust well
certainly you want from a worker trust
isn't that is it doesn't a worker say
well I want to be trust that you can pay
me trust is all the qualities of
leadership isn't that when you break
someone's trumpet is that life's all
about trust there's only one work word
and so I had no choice as much as that
paranoid and so I had to trust people I
trusted people because I wasn't capable
to do things myself and we have this
system where we translate very
trustworthy people and give them
enormous trust and as they practice that
trust they get more confirmed and being
trustworthy and eventually we've got
this seamless web of trust which is
incredibly efficient and very useful and
by the way this is not just my doctrine
there's a doctor and economics tries to
explain why firms come into existence
and firms come into existence because a
lot of people who trust one another
operating within a firm are more
efficient than they would be if they
were a bunch of independent purple
adders
full volume you you have the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or that would be
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details